riadh sidaoui bonjour bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation ce
matin sur rtl france alors idéalisant
mouammar kadhafi a été tué dans sa ville
de syrte est lynché par des combattants
l'otan avec la france et le royaume uni
a contribué à son renversement alors
aujourd'hui quelles sont les leçons
qu'on peut tirer
il ne faut pas casser un état à l'état
stable comme les américains ont cassé
l'état irakien ça veut dire la colonne
vertébrale de cet état qu'est l'armée
parce qu'en 2011 l'otan n'a pas cassé
uniquement le gouvernement ou le régime
de kadhafi mais surtout l'état depuis
2011 la libye ne jouit pas ce que max
weber l'appel la moe le monopole de la
violence légitime
ça veut dire et cela remet unique une
seule police nationale alors aujourd'hui
on a plusieurs armes et si vous
autrement dit plusieurs milices armées
qui étant divisé le pays le pays
actuellement et partagée en trois zones
la tripolitaine à l'ouest dirigé par le
gouvernement
la cyrénaïque à l'est dominé par le maïs
al-khalifa after life zen le sud donc on
est face à troyes en face à la partition
de la libye c'est le chaos total qui
règne en libye depuis 2011 pourquoi
parce qu'on a cassé l'état les biens
alors des sympathisants de mouammar
kadhafi vont se réunir aujourd'hui pour
commémorer les dix ans de sa mort qu'est
ce qu'il représente aujourd'hui
politiquement
je pense qu'ils sont assez fort le
régime en 2011 et la gagner parce qu'il
y aurait une guerre civile certes en
2011 mais les forces et les partisans de
mouammar kadhafi
c'était plus nombreux donc ils ont gagné
la bataille jusqu'à benghazi alors là
l'arrivée de temps a changé la donne
pour la donne militaire à cette époque
radicalement aujourd'hui évidemment peut
pas savoir la popularité de tel ou tel
parti politique que à travers les yeux
or les urnes la libye a une expérience
amère en juin 2014 il y a eu des
élections législatives les islamistes de
tripoli en perdu ces élections donc
n'ont pas reconnu le résultat dont
l'éclatement de parlement entre deux
eaux car le mot à tobrouk à l'est et un
parlement à l'ouest à tripoli donc
vraiment avec les élections on peut
savoir mais évidemment gaddafi reste
populaire parce que pendant son règne
certes il est autoritaire mais pendant
son règne la liberté stable forte
puissante surtout sur la scène
internationale alors en mars dernier via
un premier ministre qui a été nommé sous
l'égide de l'onu
avec un nouvel exécutif qui lui est
chargé donc d'unifier les institutions
d'assurer la transition d'ici les
élections du 24 décembre ces élections
ce scrutin ce qu'il va pouvoir se dire
se tenir dans de bonnes conditions et
est-ce que politiquement les peler
sympathisants de mouammar kadhafi
pourrait revenir
tout ce qui se passe sur le papier
concernant la question libyenne est
magnifique mais la réalité est autre
chose la réalité que les milices
persiste l'onu parle de puisque vingt
mille mercenaires et ceux des tranchées
y compris les troupes turques qui sont
toujours là qui sont toujours présents
en libye n'ont pas quitté le sol libyen
alors aussi toutes les milices tarn
évidemment le fils de mouammar kadhafi
saïf al islam kadhafi elle est assez
populaire je pense hélas beaucoup de
chance de gagner des élections mais
quelle élection on peut pas parler
d'élections avec des milices armées
parce que ce que vont perdre ces
élections
ils sont toujours armés ils ont la force
sur le terrain et si ça le paradoxe
libyen merci beaucoup en rien sidaoui
pour votre éclairage chemin tension rte
franc je le rappelle nous arickx experts
monde arabe directeur du centre arabe et
de recherches d'analystes politiques et
sociales le cas raps